let's see who else is holding on six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
how about the seven one nine area code
caller from seven one nine who's there
hi this is Jacob can you hear me
yeah go ahead Jacob what's on your mind
so my question for you is that are you
aware of and if so have you heard the
argument argument advanced by many
african-american conservatives and
libertarians that the reason why the
black community has such a low or such a
high poverty and such a high crime rate
is because of the lack of uh fathers in
the house can you still hear me yeah I
can hear hello can you hear me we can
hear you can you hear me yes yeah for
some reason my my phone went away so
okay I'm sorry about that as I was
saying the reason why these people have
said that the black primary and the
black poverty right is so high is
because of the rise in single motherhood
and the reason single motherhood Rhodes
was because the expansion of the Great
Society in the 1970s what's the response
to that argument yeah I mean you know
the response is that we can look at
correlations and causal relationships
between family structure and life
outcome and that's totally legitimate
but that as a factor in and of itself
it's a very difficult case to make that
that is the factor that has caused the
the dynamics that that you're referring
to it's sort of like when we talk about
the gender pay gap and we identify it's
not xx it's not 77 cents on the dollar
it's more like 91 or 92 cents on the
dollar and that that gap one factor is
of course gender discrimination but it's
one of many factors and so just pointing
out that gender discrimination exists
doesn't explain to us the totality of
the gender pay gap along the same lines
we can look at how family structure
correlates to educational outcomes life
outcomes stability whatever else you
want you want to say but it doesn't by
itself explain to us anything in
particular
mmm okay I think that's I think that's
an interesting and compelling this month
thank you for taking our poll and I'm a
big fan of the shade appreciate the call
that is it for live calls for today
sorry to everybody we didn't get to I
know there's a bunch of people waiting
on hold I did my best and we will take
calls again